hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to underhell that means
you wanted to see us so calm down and
let us do our job yeah yeah yeah yeah
whatever
yes I am this is the best that we could
get I show that obscured the windows on
the first and third row or the location
that if anything happens anywhere else
this is the best buy okay
we've also gotten at the back inside
doors now that this spot is comfort they
don't know where to go yeah that's right
and I get to snipe some people right oh
hello lady
Oh Showtime oh hello boo-boo oh come on
there we go boo-boo and why is that guy
still shooting anymore come on uh-huh
I've never good at sniping parts huh hey
Jake oh no oh no no no no whatever a
loud no don't kill her now do it all
right
I missed again there we go man
she can take some bullets Oh God I never
was good at any sniping parts in any
game at least she's alive maybe I don't
know here before you go away you might
want to grab this yeah cuz uh no I
probably won't where to go look at where
to go Oh shotgun right no I can I can
hold it all like a blouse what are you
thinking why am I going back downstairs
now is that what's happening
am I going I'm going oh oh hello okay
now I guess I'm going downstairs and
Rudy's run all the way I took all that
time to get up here why didn't you go oh
okay
mmm
I get choices okay I don't need look I'm
some super hotshot mega ultra SWAT guy
on the world's best sniper slash
crappiest sniper flash expert agent
preacher okay which way I go uh oh here
we go whoo hello signal oh god oh god
good how are you still alive oh hello
you might want to there we go shoot
there we go goodness gracious I was not
expecting these controls
all right can I go in here yes I can
hello goodbye boom excuse me for chair
get what what the hell a chair did a
triple backflip I don't know hello Oh
Hospital it should be lovely oh did you
die good job way to fail oh well that's
very nightmare house asking hello you're
dead you're dead you're dead and anybody
in here that needs to be dead now okay
all right then I guess I could have gone
in the back that way boom Thank You
Bangi
hey who's there to the left thought I
saw someone hey there move thank you
and do move
hide your eyes her Bruce come on what
the hell
what are you invincible what are you
like that lady's brother who is on the
roof
excuse me
how about could rouse through me how
about you die
there we go it's about damn time I'm
switching weapons shotguns sucks and out
loses food and reverb murmurs murmurs
murmurs murmurs oh hang on a second I
need to reload here Bruce thank you oh
hello I miss you
there we go another day oh hello for the
others nothing your time thanks where
that lady go no you're not to help to
anybody disability
okay okay
all right and where's this ah hello
thank you I'm taking over hey buddy you
don't look so good
also you're full of holes boom just cuz
it was ugly as well any second now made
some elevator music to cut the time any
second now world longest loading screen
oh there you are
I wasn't worried that I'd have to talk
fill the time with actual dialogue of
ridiculous oh hello boom thank you
anybody else down here
oh hello hey this looks good no we're
not
as a lie didn't stand a chance I am so
great at everything out boy yep this is
where things go bad this is where
everything goes wrong oh hello
hey stop that
stop it stop it
ooh what's all this then it was supposed
to be an underground parking garage of
life hi
giving oh now Wow that actually hurts
hey stop it
I said stop it for you pick the worst
hiding places there no kidding
please
okay
that sounds about right I need to get it
hang on either gonna help boop-boop-boop
reduce another one
thank you feels good man pistol
hi there bloom bloom bloom
blam-blam-blam- ii bloom Blamey bloom
bloom bloom bloom bloom bloom blame me
blame me oh you didn't die
okay one second a bang bang blew me bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang boom
boom boom boom I'm just digging around
til the actual like a scary part get
started here kaboom did that kill you I
opened it up and boom boom boom boom
thank you kaboom kaboom hello nice oh
hello
secondary's come by me oh hi didn't see
you there a bang a movie about bound by
bang hello
I suppose I have a sniper rifle
there we go I'm right here you don't
need to talk about me it will suck bad
names I have feelings ooh hello what oh
hello all right there's only one of me
there's much more effective even though
I'm not good with sniper rifles come on
out come on out buddy all right never
mind I'm coming over
hello oh hi boom head showers hello boom
not quiet head shout next shout hellooo
you throw a grenade now he shot that who
did that who did that who the hell had
the audacity oh I need to go back to say
was that a level 10 you know nothing
about 10 where did he go someone was
shooting at me I mean I felt these
totally harmless grazing flies landing
on my face and neck I was just assuming
there were bullets oh shout gun time
again was that oh it's a wrench
I need a wrench we don't need a wrench
boom
mrow glow stick batteries must be
gearing me up for something I didn't
know this oh hello okay
nothing I can't handle
yeah it's like that that's the way it be
they don't think it'd be like it is but
it dude someone's shooting at me from
behind but I mean every time I look back
all things seems to be happy
hi bye nice lights that HDR lighting I
didn't know they include then the source
engine must be the later update ever
mine probably Nydia oh do I get to hop
on a train I do come on come on come on
where's your train oh that's not a right
train let's not jump into the trailer
jump on the train Hey oh come on
Oh jumping on it oh wait no maybe I'm
not supposed to oh I'm supposed to not
get myself killed
oh oh hi there hi
that would have been bad I hope I don't
run out of Sprint juice oh I'm running
out of Sprint juice oh okay I'm okay
whoa what happened to this guy oh we got
cut in half by the train
maybe on here as everyone who owns a
shotgun knows you [ __ ] it every time you
pull it out you know I mean here we go
Oh who's shooting at me now someone
decided to throw some bullets my way
they're obviously not using a gun oh
hello hmm
hi there oh you need some boom bang in
your life trains can't hide you now
thank you I guess a sniper rifle would
it be a bit more effectively boom a bang
II let's see yeah I still don't know
what's going on I assumed then at some
point things are about to take a turn
for the worst
alright what do I do here I got to get
across must be way up ah here we go
ooh nice suits as Barney Stinson always
says suit up oh oh no the loading screen
I wonder if this one's gonna take as
long as the next one last one I mean I
hope they all take this long cuz
analysis you and me it's just you and me
right here alone forever
don't look behind you huh
I almost spilled my water again would
have been bad to destroy another
keyboard and who's up here let me guess
another bunch of people that want to
throw bullets at me face at me face what
I can't go this way
oh yes yes oh here we go got it nailed
it all right what am i going up or down
well actually I'm going nowhere because
I'm actually all at a time thank you
guys so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye